[Music]
so the past
year and a half i've really been made
aware
of the intimate relationship between our
psychology
and our physiology it seemed like as we
were locked
down physically we were also locked down
mentally
as we felt kind of stuck in our own
homes and
in our apartments we also felt stuck
inside our own heads
we fell into cyclical thinking and i
think a lot of that has to do with the
fact that there weren't
fresh inputs no fresh experiences being
added into our lives
so we didn't have novel ideas it was all
exacerbated as well by the fact that the
algorithms that we are likely
leaning on heavily through youtube and
netflix and twitter and all of that
learn what we tend to click on so we
start to develop these
deep digital grooves into certain topics
of interest
and you start getting recommended the
same content day in and day out
and you start to wonder like why am i
stuck in a rut why am i thinking the
same things that i'm thinking all the
time
and how come i can't get out of this
pattern you know when you take a step
back from it all it all becomes pretty
obvious but when you're trapped in it
it's hard to gain the perspective that
you need
to get out of that situation and into a
better one and that's another thing
that's really become apparent about
human nature
over the past year is that when we don't
have that exterior influence when we
don't
talk to new people when we don't have a
sort of an outside network and we're
just trapped inside our own heads
it's almost always a really bad thing
over a long period of time this
isolation
almost always breeds a pessimism
negative thought patterns
while it might be good to be alone
sometimes and learn to be alone with
yourself
too much of that too much isolation
almost
always corrupts us you know it seems
like human beings
operate optimally when we're working
together
when we're giving each other new ideas
when we're helping each other out
when we're carrying a load and accepting
responsibility to help
the group and it's this putting yourself
out there
this voluntary acceptance of
responsibility
that kind of gives life its meaning the
existential dread of existence can be
kept at bay
when it feels like you're contributing
to something as we play a role in these
sub communities in these sports teams in
these book clubs in these
volunteer opportunities our life seems
bigger and more optimistic
full of more opportunity we're not so
trapped inside our own pessimistic way
of thinking
i feel like this is all because there's
an intimate link between our
psychology and the physical space that
we take up
you know the places we go and the people
we interact with
are extensions of our consciousness and
through these external influences
we gain access to new ideas new ways of
thinking
and we unlock parts of the brain that we
would not have access to
in solitude there's a reason why so many
self-improvement junkies or gurus or
psychologists navy seals will tell you
to
make your bed clean your room organize
the physical space around you
you know jocko willing jordan peterson
you name it these people are all saying
that the physical environment in which
you are a part of
is an extension of yourself and
following the same train of thought
i would also say the physical size the
literal
square footage of your physical
surroundings
is sort of the square footage of your
mental surroundings of your existential
surroundings
and that feels weird to say but i feel
like people kind of know this
instinctually
if you never ever leave your house and
you're just trapped living the same day
over and over and over
again then your existence really starts
to feel small
the literal amount of things that you
influence on a day-to-day basis
is quite small your life can start to
feel very insignificant
you don't actually make a difference in
the world as much as you would if you
were
out there interacting with more things
and it's the same reason why people who
travel a lot they get back from a year
of traveling
they have so many new ideas and
perspectives and they're so
inspired and full of life and that's
because by physically traveling to new
places
they mentally travel to new places as
well
their existence seems larger and if you
don't have the luxury to travel around
everywhere at your
whims and i know a lot of people
absolutely don't this still applies to
whatever
town or city you live in it applies to
the activities that you say yes or no to
by actually saying yes to that salsa
dancing class
or that brazilian jujitsu class or
saying yes to playing volleyball on the
beach with
your brother and his wife you know these
things matter
new experiences open your world up and
make your life
feel more significant this was all just
basically a long-winded way of saying
get outside you know obviously not in a
way that will hurt or endanger anybody
but you guys are smart
by injecting yourself into the world
around you instead of
hiding away in a tower like rapunzel
you'll actually start to feel like you
have some autonomy over your own life
so good luck and get off youtube
but if you're still here i would love to
take the opportunity to thank
a very unique sponsor of today's video
and that is
cuts now cuts is a clothing company that
i've been wearing for months and months
and months
they are i'm actually wearing a cuts
shirt right now i've been wearing a cut
shirt in the past like five videos or so
and they are by far the best fitting
best made
most breathable shirts i have ever worn
and
cuts is hooking you guys up with 15 off
your order if you use my link in the
description below
or use the coupon code joey at checkout
so if you guys are looking forward to
injecting yourself into the world and
imposing your will upon society and you
want to look fresh when you're doing it
then check out cuts and buy yourself the
best shirt that you'll ever wear
and if you like this video make sure you
actually hit like
because when you hit like the algorithm
says hey this was a pretty cool video
and i'm going to recommend it to more
people
and that helps them out and helps me out
so it's a win-win for everybody
and if you're lurking here consider
subscribing other than that
thank you so much for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video